we're going to begin with breaking news
from Ukraine which is facing yet another
day of brutal Russian attacks multiple
cities have been hit again today after
dozens of missiles and drones were
launched yesterday with targets all
across the country many hit neighbor
neighborhoods rather full of civilians
at the height of Rush Hour Ukrainian
government says at least 19 people were
killed by the first round of these
strikes and more than a hundred injured
Charlie daggers in Ukraine for more on
the story Charlie good morning to you
good morning to you Gail more rocket
attacks overnight as you said Air Raid
Sirens here and across the country
zaparisia targeted once again the
Ukrainian military said more than 75
cruise missiles were fired into Ukraine
around 40 of them were intercepted
roughly two dozen Iranian suicide drones
were used to
this morning Ukraine is still reeling
from the onslaught surveying the damage
counting the costs and the dead an
assault that sent residents of Kiev back
into Subways and shelters
where they sang Ukrainian folk songs and
the national anthem in defiance but
while President Putin may have proved
Russia has the reach and the
recklessness to rain missiles down on
civilians his soldiers are taking a
beating on the battlefield we travel
toward the front lines in the South to
curse on where Ukraine's troops have
recaptured territory in a lightning
counter-attack measured daily by the
mile these Villages were among the first
to fall to Russia under its grip for
seven months until they were liberated
not much more than a week ago Oksana was
still in a state of disbelief what did
you think when you first saw Ukrainian
soldiers here
happiness she said I was just very happy
she fought back tears as she described
life under Russian occupation
we visited the high school it had been
repurposed by Russian soldiers as a
military headquarters the aftermath
tells the story of the battle that took
place here huge chunks of concrete taken
out of the wall every window smashed the
scorched buildings and the burnt out
armored personnel carriers still bearing
the Z of the Russian army
where we found School teachers Svetlana
resnichenko taking stock of the filth
and squalor that looked more like the
remnants of a ragtag militia than
professional soldiers
when I came in and saw this horror she
said I still had faith that we will
rebuild everything
there is more rebuilding ahead and more
fighting too Putin may have proven
capable of destroying civilian life yet
his Elite troops have proven incapable
of even holding ground
now in addition to the air raid sirens
there have been new alarms that blast
out on cell phones including ours early
this morning Ukraine's infrastructure
has taken a real pounding businesses
have been asked to shut down at 6 pm to
conserve electricity Gail
oh the images are tough Charlie as you
know president zielinski he's going to
make a brief appearance at the emergency
G7 meeting later today so we'll see if
there's any help on the way we thank you
Charlie dagada